bit by bit I'm able to build a 3d
picture I can see how well alligators
design these dwellings to last
throughout the winter the entrances I
measured are about two meters wide
inside the main passageway eventually
turns and there's usually a depression
that holds a water supply that's
something that may help the Gators get
through a long winter the floor is just
too rugged the Brady car is stuck I've
got my remote-control car about 25 feet
into this burrow and it's down I'm
afraid if I pull the camera wire only
the camera will come out
there's only one thing to do once more
into the Burrow headfirst into the
alligators lair I never liked coming to
abandon the tunnel if I get a hard left
turn you never know what's gonna be on
the other side
you never know what you gonna run into
I heard something
and you get in here and you start
hearing things I mean it is a scary
place to be no no no there's some hey
hey there's something
I grabbed the car and it's camera turns
to this
your dick
somebody's home I thought this alligator
burrow was empty I came in to get my
remote camera vehicle and I got way more
than I bargained for right there
he's just sitting there looking at me
hissing that's telling me that the Gator
is not happy this is its refuge very
surprised to see a person in here as
tight a spot as this is for me it looks
like there's plenty of room for more
than one Gator but this is a female
alligator she may have her babies in
here
the moms take the whole family and they
all spend the winter together in the
deepest portion of these burrows we do
not want to measure this burrow